Next we're going to be speaking with
John Kansky, the interim president and
CEO of
the Indiana Health Information Exchange.
Well, John, I want to thank you for
taking the time to be
with us this morning and
to help the students learn more about
the Indiana Health Information Exchange.
They're already aware of the challenges,
the financial challenges,
the sustainability challenges faced
by health information exchanges.
As you look around the country,
where do you think we are on that?
>> I, yeah thanks, Mark.
The sustainability has
long been discussed and
debated as a key part of health
information exchange and
I think it's helpful to view that in
terms of the three types of health
information exchanges that have
merged in the marketplace.
There are a number of state run
exchanges run by their respective state
governments, largely funded by
our recent era high tech funding.
There are private or proprietary
exchanges that are run by and
controlled by single organization like
a large health system for example.
And then there's the type of exchange
which I think most of us have been
thinking about for a number of years,
and the type of exchange that we
are in Indiana which I call a regional
inter-organization exchange.
We have to sustain
ourselves by delivering
services that our customers
value in exchange for fees, and
making sure that those fees, the revenue
from those fees exceed our expenses.
The other two types of exchanges,
the state run and
the proprietary,in some cases have
the opportunity to be sustained by their
sort of parent organizations.
If the state government chooses
to levy attacks or generate or
provide dollars from the general
fund of the state government,
they really don't have
a sustainability challenge.
And in the case of the proprietary or
private exchange,
they're sort of sustained at the whim
of the organization that runs it, so
I feel that question is most
interesting for the region exchanges.
And again, we really have to run
ourselves like a business or
despite the fact that many of us
are not for profit organizations,
you need to be very conscious of
having revenue in excess of expenses.
The way to do that is to focus
on services that your customers
value enough to pay for.
It sounds fairly mundane and it sounds
more like a business class than
informatics, but it's very important for
HIEs to remember to sustain themselves.
>> The students are familiar with what
IHIE does thanks to some examples
that you sent before the class.
Let's take a moment and look at
what it takes to do those things.
Can you tell us a bit about
the IHIE organization?
>> Sure, absolutely.
And again, stressing that our, we're not
affiliated with the state government,
but certainly have a good
relationship with them.
We're a non-for-profit
501 C3 organization.
We have a board of health care
stakeholders from across the state
including many of our large customers.
We have a governance body which
is extraordinarily important.
Which governs the data
use of our data and
allows, it provides for
confidence between competing
organizations to share their data and
have it used for our services.
And the structure of our organization,
we're about 54 people separated
into three management stacks.
One which is software and
product development,
one which is all the customer
facing functions like support,
implementation and customer relationship
management and product strategy.
And then finally a third stack which
is largely IT infrastructure and
administrative function.
>> At the heart of all this, of course,
is this normalized,
curated database of clinical information
that you've accumulated from the many
different kinds and varieties and
brands of EMRs that I'm sure in
use across the state of Indiana.
How do you do that?
How do you bring all that
together into something that for
example can create the Indiana
network for patient care.
Which makes every patient look as though
they have a single record even though
that date may be,
may exist in many different EMRs.
>> So how we do that is through
many real time interfaces.
And an ongoing task of
what we call data mapping,
which a little bit more specifically
is semantic normalization of the data.
The best way to explain that, that I've
found, is that we like to say that
one organization will send
us their data in Italian.
Another organization
sends it in Portuguese.
will send it in German.
We translate everything to Latin,
so that we can combine it into that
virtual patient, single patient record,
that you referenced.
That gives us the ability, which is
really the key for our past, present and
the future that we're
going to be able to deliver.
That gives you the ability to look at
a patient's record at the point of care
as if it came from one place, even
though the data came from many places.
It also gives you the opportunity
to analyze across a population or
to manage the health of a population
using data, knowing that you
have the complete view of that
population, patient by patient.
It is very expensive.
I want to acknowledge that.
To put the labor into normalizing
the data and maintaining the interfaces
which gets back to that
question of sustainability and
having to work very hard to make sure
you're delivering value to customers
to cover the cost of that semantically
normalized system of repositories.
>> Well, that's very interesting.
I've used you as the primary example
of centralized HIE in the course.
Does IHIE see a role for some of
the newer technologies designed for
a federated environment?
Technologies such as Direct,
RESTful APIs and more recently Fire.
>> Sure.
Let me start by commenting that we
describe ourselves as a centrally
managed federated structure.
Meaning our repositories,
the data in our repositories,
continues to be owned and
legally controlled by the organizations
that provide the data to us.
It's not our data.
But it is centrally managed in a single
data center which gives us
the best of both worlds.
We have the performance of a centrally
managed structure with the governance
advantages and comfort of the providers
knowing that it's federated.
But that's not the question
that you asked.
So, let me comment on some of the newer,
emerging standards.
This is a very practical answer because
HIEs have to be practical organizations.
We can only base our services on
what's available in the marketplace.
So using Direct as an example, Direct
is one of the newer standards that's
finding its way driven by meaningful
use into the marketplace.
And to that extent, we are providing
services based on Direct.
Some of the other standards that
are still evolving, we pay attention to.
We study, we try to anticipate.
We try and participate at a federal
level in learning about and
influencing those standards but
we of necessity to sustain ourselves,
base our services only on those
that are in the marketplace and
to an extent Direct is
emerging as a useful standard.
>> Well, thank you.
And to conclude, as you look
toward the future, all right.
Can you tell us what additional services
or directions you see IHIE going?
>> Certainly, and this is an interesting
area for us because you always have to
be responsive to what your
customers are looking for next and
what In our business what
the government is steering towards.
So, I took a couple of notes of
things that I thought might be worth
highlighting.
For example, one of the things
we have done in the past, but
we know we're going to
be doing a lot more of.
And, I wanted to stress, because,
I don't believe there are many, if any,
other HIEs doing this is
that we are increasingly
able to put structured data from our
repository system into the EHR's in
response to some clinical event.
So for example,
say a patient shows up at the emergency
department of a hospital.
We're able to take data from
the repository corresponding to that
patient, matching them with
their identity on the fly and
send that data, which comes from many,
many other sources outside the
enterprise where they just presented,
and deposit that data electronically
in the EHR at that facility.
That's something we've only
accomplished with a couple
of different organizations
in our customer base and
it's been those that have been somewhat
more sophisticated in terms of their IT.
But I definitely see things going
that way, if for no other reason than
we don't want physicians, clinicians to
be pulled out of their native EHR, but
still need to be able to view data
from outside the organization.
One more example well,
I'll give two quickly.
Medication data is something
that's in great demand and
high value at the point of care.
We're working hard to increase the
amount and make it more comprehensive.
In terms of the data that we can
make available at the point of care,
we've always done that but it's a very
difficult thing to try to aggregate.
It's worth noting that that even means
working with the state legislature
in Indiana to sometimes influence policy
to make the data more available and
remove obstacles.
The last thing that is,
I think, worth noting,
is analytics is a word that is thrown
around quite a bit these days,
almost to the point that it loses
its meaning without being defined.
There's a lot of things
in that category.
We've already tried a couple of
things in the analytics space,
with mixed success and
it's a great question I think for
HIEs whether the marketplace
is going to expect them to
analyze the data that they
are able to acquire and aggregate.
Or whether the market is expecting
them only to provide the data and
not necessarily the analysis.
I think that's an open question.
>> Well John, this has been
a fascinating conversation.
IHIE is something that anyone
interested in health informatics
needs to know about and
needs to follow and I
appreciate your taking the time today to
help the students understand it better.
>> Happy to do it.
Thank you.